hey what is up everybody it's annamac
here for anime operor and in this video
i will be breaking down the death of
every single upper demon moon in the
demon slayer series this includes those
who died in battle and those who died in
other ways the upper demon moons are the
most powerful and most important
villains in the series after demon king
muzon himself so the deaths of these
characters had a profound impact on the
whole story that is why i decided to
break them all down right here in one
place for your convenience you guys know
the drill if you enjoy our demonstrator
content it would help me a lot if you
just left a comment and a like it only
takes a second but it really helps with
that youtube algorithm and of course if
you're new here or maybe you watch our
videos but you just haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a favor and
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications it is a totally
free but very important way of directly
supporting this channel finally this
video will contain demon slayer manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned
now the 12 demon moons also known as the
12 kizuki are a group of 12 demons who
are directly under the command of demon
daddy himself muzan kibutsuji these 12
are supposed to be the strongest demons
in existence aside from muzon himself
and they were made so strong by the fact
that muzon personally gave them
significant amounts of his own blood
that said the 12 demon moons are made up
of two separate groups the six lower
demon moons and the six upper demon
moons the lower moons have a number
corresponding to their rank engraved
into one of their eyes while the upper
moons have that number engraved into
both of their eyes with that in mind in
this video i will be focusing on the
upper moons because let's face it the
lower demon moons are not nearly as
strong and of course a bunch of them
were just killed by muzon in a matter of
seconds because he was disappointed in
their abilities after that the lower
moons were basically abolished we know
of multiple instances in which both
hashira and even non-hashira demon
slayers were able to defeat lower demon
moons but until the fight against daki
and yutaro inside the entertainment
district no upper moon had been killed
in 113
years meanwhile dozens of hashira have
been slain by upper moons during that
same period of time so clearly the upper
moons are on a completely different
level from the lower moons and the gap
in their strength is just massive now
since i mentioned daki and yutaro let's
talk about how they became the first
upper moon to be defeated by demon
slayers in over 100 years
ducky is introduced as someone who plays
the part of an odan inside the
entertainment district and we know that
she's been alive for over a century for
that entire time she has been using the
position of an oiran in order to gain
access to all the privileges that an
oiran enjoys while also being able to
use the entertainment district as
fertile hunting grounds daki has been
changing her name and identity in order
to hide the fact that she is an immortal
demon but other than that she has been
living within a fairly established
comfort zone since first becoming a
demon once in a while she has to silence
someone who realizes that she's actually
been alive for generations but that
doesn't seem to pose a big problem for
her when he comes to visit ducky in
person muza notices that she has gotten
much stronger because she has been
devouring so many humans we also learned
that she has killed seven hashira in the
past and muzon says that he has high
hopes for her the first to engage daki
in battle is tanjiro he quickly realizes
that dakizobi has special powers it
allows her to hide herself and other
people inside of it and then move
through small cracks in walls she used
this obi to capture hide and devour
countless human victims and as a result
she has been getting stronger and
stronger for over a hundred years
tanjiro is no match for daki at first
and he even manages to chip his blade
but by using hinokamikagura
he learns to fight back now tanjiro puts
up an impressive showing against daki
and even seems to get the upper hand for
a while but then his body gives out
under all the strain that he was putting
it through this then forces nezuko to
come out of hiding and engage daki in
order to protect tanjiro who is on the
verge of death at this point fueled by
the anger she feels for the loss of her
family at the hands of demons nezuko is
able to tap into incredible levels of
demonic power and this allows her to
accomplish some incredible things like
regenerating lost limbs practically
instantly using this newfound power in
her blood demon art nezuko actually
wrecks ducky and it looks like the
battle is over but then nezuko loses
control of her demon side and she goes
berserk
sensing the blood that is pouring from
the wounds of nearby humans she snaps
and attempts to devour a human
thankfully tangero is able to subdue her
and prevent her from doing that but it
takes all of his physical power and all
of his lullaby singing skills to pull it
off it's a good thing that tanjiro
prevented nezuko from devouring that
human because he giu and sakonji made a
promise that if nezuko were to ever hurt
a human all three of them would give up
their own lives with nezuko being
restrained by tanjiro a furious ducky
decides to kill both of them and all the
innocent bystanders in the area but
before she can do that tengen shows up
and relieves her of her head so quickly
that no one even notices that he did it
tengan then states that ducky is too
weak to be an upper demon moon so she
must not be the upper moon that he came
here to fight
an angry and distraught ducky then
begins acting like a petulant child and
she calls out for her older brother
whose name is gyutero a strange
emaciated creature then emerges from
ducky's back and this misshapen demon is
ducky's older brother it's clear right
away that gyutaro is much much stronger
than ducky and that he is the true upper
moon 6. now technically they are both
upper moon 6 but it is only because of
gyutaro's strength that they reached
this rank daki's strength does not
compare the demon known as gyutaro
consoles his little sister and then he
turns to face tangent gyutaro claims
that he has killed 15 hashira over the
course of his long lifespan and that is
in addition to the seven that daki
claims to have killed this is evidence
that the hashira of this generation are
clearly more powerful than the hashira
of previous generations tengen who is
not even considered to be the strongest
hashira was able to take daki out with
ease despite the fact that she
apparently killed the seven hashira from
previous generations a fierce battle
then commences between tengen and yutaro
and as the battle progresses we learned
that daki and yutaro are intrinsically
connected and that they depend on each
other daki becomes stronger once guterre
awakens and yutero has the ability to
see through daki's eyes which allows him
to get a better view of the entire
battlefield kyotaro also has the ability
to control daki which again serves as a
reminder that gyotaro is the stronger
sibling and the main component of upper
moon 6. but gyutaro isn't always
controlling daki and she does have her
own free will on top of that we also
learned that the only way to defeat daki
and yutaro is to relieve both of them of
their heads at exactly the same time
inosuke sleep mode zenitsu and tanjiro
soon join the fight against daki and
yutaro and they provide badly needed
backup for tangent inosuke intended to
take charge of fighting ducky while
tangent and tanjiro assume the task of
fighting yutaro and we even get some
assists from tengen's awesome and hot
ninja wives through the fight we learned
that dakia and yutaro suffered greatly
in their past and the way that they deal
with this injustice is by inflicting
suffering upon others as revenge for how
they themselves were treated they
learned the dark and cruel nature of
this world back when they were still
human children and so they show no mercy
to anyone just like no one showed any
mercy to them whenever they cause harm
to someone who had an easier life than
them they see it as collecting on the
debt that is owed to them by the rest of
the world they want to cause misery to
others equal to the unhappiness that
they themselves experienced the
multifaceted battle against upper moon 6
is one of the best fights in the entire
series many people thought that this
fight was even better than the fights in
the mugen train movie a movie whose
success was unprecedented and honestly i
have to agree i loved mugen train and
the main fight against akaza was a
masterpiece but i think that the
entertainment district arc of the anime
actually managed to outdo the movie at
one point in the battle tanjiro joins
inosuke and zenitsu in fighting doki and
thanks to the team effort inosuke
actually manages to take her head and
run away with it however inosuke is
quickly stopped by gutaro who catches up
to him and stabs him from behind with
his sickle before taking daki's head
back inosuke's wound looks really bad at
first glance and it appears that he may
have been stabbed through the heart
which would mean that he is practically
dead already at the same time tengan's
lifeless body is lying on the ground
below and it looks like he too might be
dead after succumbing to the poison with
which gyutero laced his weapons then
zenitsu gets crushed by a bunch of
rubble and it soon appears that tanjiro
is the last one of the good guys left
standing although technically he isn't
even standing he is down on the ground
and he can barely see as a result of all
the strain that he has put his body
through yutero approaches tanjiro and
mocks him for failing to protect his
younger sister even though that is his
duty as her older brother yutaro
belittles tanjido and all humans for
being pathetic and weak and even breaks
two of tanjiro's fingers just for the
fun of it i guess in this moment things
look extremely bad for the good guys
gyutaro offers tanjiro a lifeline by
telling him to become a demon if he does
that then his body would become strong
rather than weak and pathetic and he
could actually protect his sister
instead of failing miserably oh and if
tanjiro refuses to become a demon then
gyotaro vows to kill both him and nezuko
but instead of entertaining yutaro's
proposal tanjiro gives yutara one of his
famous headbutts to the face the
headbutt itself won't do much to a demon
but tanjiro was smart enough to use the
headbutt as a distraction in order to
also stab yutaro with a poisoned kunai
at the same time gyutaro is temporarily
immobilized by the wisteria poison on
the kunai and tanjiro takes that
opportunity to try and take gyotaro's
head at the same time that this is
happening zenitsu returns to the fight
and he uses thunderclap and flash
godspeed to try to take donkey's head
off despite being weakened by poison
yutaro is still too strong for tanjiro
to be able to take him down and the more
time passes the more guitar recovers
from the poison thankfully tengen comes
to the rescue even though guterre
thought that tengen had died because his
heart had stopped in reality tengen used
his ninja training to temporarily stop
his heart which also slowed the
circulation of poison through his veins
tangan then used this opportunity that
tanjiro created to jump into the fight
again tengen and tanjiro managed to take
gutaro's head after tanjiro unlocks the
full potential of his demon slayer mark
at the same time inosuke helps zenit to
be head docky even though it appeared as
if inosuke had been stabbed through the
heart because he has the ability to
dislodge his bones and move the organs
in his body around he managed to survive
and then he snuck up on daki at just the
right time as both of their heads lie
dying daki and guterro start arguing
about which one of them is to blame for
their defeat but the kind-hearted
tanjiro reminds them that all they have
left is each other no one else will miss
them when they're gone everyone will
curse them for being demons and doing
horrible things to so many people so now
as they lie dying they must stop this
petty bickering they don't really mean
what they're saying so they shouldn't go
off into the afterlife fighting although
they resisted first tanjiru's words do
eventually get through to them daki and
yutara regained their memories from back
when they were human and they remember
the promise that they made to each other
the promise that they will always be
together and so they head off into hell
together with yutaro carrying his sister
on his back like he had done so many
times before when they were kids
ducky and yutaro's entire backstory is
actually great but doing a deep dive
into backstories is not the topic of
this video the main takeaway is that the
two of them were villains in the true
sense of the word they didn't regret
becoming demons they didn't regret the
evil things that they had done and they
ended up in hell together because of it
but even so you can still sympathize
with their truly tragic story they were
in fact treated horribly by other people
when they were human and they themselves
then treated other people horribly their
entire life was one giant cycle of
suffering hatred and revenge and in the
end their story is a double-edged sword
of tragedy on the one side we have the
tragedy that the two of them suffered
and on the other side we have the
tragedy that they willingly brought upon
other innocent people
next up let's talk about upper moon 5
gyoko and upper moon 4 hunting gu who
both meet their end during the
swordsmith village arc when we first see
them in that meeting of the upper moons
that muzan called after the defeat of
upper moon 6 huntengu gives the
impression of being a meek timid and
superstitious old man although he
certainly looks creepy because he is
after all a demon he doesn't look very
threatening especially when compared to
the other demon moons meanwhile gyoko is
a demon who kind of looks like a genie
and who we see emerging from a vase
gyoko seems to like using sarcasm with
his fellow demon moons but with muzon he
is just eager to please him gyoko keeps
talking about how he has important
information about the demon slayers and
how that makes him more useful to muzan
than the others at the end of the
meeting huntengu and gyoko are
dispatched by muzon on a big mission it
turns out that gyoko managed to find the
top secret location of the swordsmith
village a critically important demon
slayer sanctuary and so the two demon
moons set out to infiltrate and attack
the village gyoko makes his appearance
inside the village after an unsuspecting
villager stumbles upon a vase in the
middle of a path as he reaches for the
vase he is sucked in and devoured but
gyoko then spits him back up saying that
it tastes terrible because the flesh of
mir swordsmiths is not high quality
enough for him gyoko clearly has bigger
fish to fry
at around the same time huntengu is seen
crawling on the roof of one of the
buildings in the middle of the night han
tengu knows that muzon is angry and they
have to hurry and prove their usefulness
to him right away and the way that he
and gyoko plan to prove their usefulness
is by killing everyone inside the
swordsmith village which would be a
major blow for the demon slayer core as
muichiro and tanjiro are talking while
nezuko sleeps huntinggu just randomly
crawls into the same room that they are
in hantengu is so good at hiding his
presence that the demon sayers didn't
even realize he was there until they saw
him with their own eyes muichiro and
tanjiro attempt to engage huntengu but
strangely he only seems to be dodging
and screaming at them to stop being mean
to him eventually muichiro succeeds in
taking off the demon's head but instead
of dying huntangu splits into two
different demons the head grows another
body and the original body grows another
head the two new demons look completely
different than hunting who did they look
younger and stronger and they use
completely different names genya then
shows up and both demons are beheaded
but again instead of dying the demons
split once more creating four separate
demons tangero warns the others that
this demon cannot be defeated in the
conventional sense hantengu actually
wants them to attack him and take off
his head because that makes him multiply
and get even stronger after one of the
demon's attacks sends muichiro flying
into the distance he rushes to get back
to the battle but on his way back to
tundra and the others he encounters a
demonic fish creature that was clearly
created by a powerful demon this fish
demon was getting its power from a vase
which means that it was created by gyoko
the fish demon thing doesn't pose a
challenge to muichiro but he does
eventually come face to face with gyoko
himself gyoko being the sick individual
that he is proudly parades around the
bodies of five swordsmiths that he has
killed and then arranged into some sort
of grotesque art piece he starts
babbling on about the artistic merits of
his creation but muichiro cuts him off
and engages him in battle gyoko is able
to evade muichiro's attacks by traveling
instantly between the different pots and
vases that he had already arranged
throughout the entire area gyoko is able
to launch poison needles at muichiro and
he then manages to use his blood demon
art to capture muichiro inside a giant
pot filled with water with muichiro
unable to breathe he cannot use his
breathing style effectively and so it
looks like he is about to die gyoko
leaves muichiro to die and moves on but
after gyoko leaves muichiro is rescued
thanks to a young swordsmith named
kotatsu who helps muichiro at great cost
to himself kotatsu's sacrifice imbues
muichiro with a drive to help others and
this allows him to unlock his demon
slayer mark now stronger than ever
before muichiro confronts gyoko gyoko
uses his blood demon art to throw a
bunch of squid and fish and other
seafood products at muichiro but the
hashira is able to use mist breathing to
repel all of those attacks and yeah i
know that saying he throws a bunch of
seafood doesn't sound scary but they're
all super deadly attacks okay
gyoko is then forced to reveal his true
form in which he appears to be some sort
of half man half eel creature a ruthless
battle ensues but the newly powered up
muichiro is full of confidence and he is
just too strong for gyoko using missed
breathing seventh form obscuring clouds
he emerges from the mist and relieves
gyoko of his head muichiro's success
came from the fact that he was able to
use wildly fluctuating speed in his
movements to confuse gyoko and in the
end the hashida's superb speed and
technique was just too much for the
demon gyoko cannot believe that he was
defeated by a mere human child but it
was precisely that overconfidence that
destroyed gyoko in the end he could have
finished off muichiro while the hashira
was drowning inside that pot but he just
assumed that muichiro was done for and
he was distracted by other things this
was his downfall back in the battle
against hantengu tanjiro realizes that
there are four main demons and each one
has a different word in its mouth joy
anger sorrow and pleasure if these four
divide any further they don't become any
stronger in fact the more they divide
the weaker their individual attacks
become tanjiro also realizes that if he
can damage the tongues of these demons
then they will regenerate more slowly
during the fight nezuko uses her blood
demon art to set tanjiro's sword on fire
and the resulting heat along with
nezuko's blood turns tanjiro's blade red
this is highly significant because
bright red nichiren blades can burn
demons on a cellular level which
prevents them from regenerating the
legendary yorichi tsugikuni the breath
of the sun user also had a black blade
like tanjiro but it could turn bright
red during battle with his burning red
blade tanjiro uses hinokamikagura's sun
halo dragon head dance to decapitate
three of the four huntengu demons at the
same time genya is able to take the head
of the fourth one but even though the
regeneration of the demons has slowed
down they are still not dying and that's
when tangier realizes that there is a
fifth demon out there a fifth body must
be destroyed in order for huntengu to be
defeated thanks to tangero's sensitive
nose genya is able to locate the fifth
and main body this body looks like the
original huntangu himself but it is tiny
about the size of a mouse huntengu is
using that small size to hide so as to
prevent his main body from being
attacked genya and tanjiro attempt to
kill him but then a new demon shows up
to protect the miniature hunting gu this
sixth demon is actually the other four
demons coming together to create a new
demon hunting will get stronger whenever
he is cornered or in fear for his life
and the more pressure he is feeling the
stronger he becomes the sixth demon
hatred is the ultimate embodiment of
that strength the new demon gains a
decisive advantage over tanjiro nezuko
and genya in battle but that is when the
love hashira mitsuri comes to the rescue
mitsuri uses her superhuman flexibility
and agility along with the thin and
flexible nature of her unique sword to
counter the demon's overwhelming attacks
she is nearly killed at one point after
taking a massive attack head-on but her
incredible muscle density allows her to
survive the attack and she is then
pulled to safety by tanjiro kenya and
nezuko mitsuri gets back into the battle
raises her heart rate and like muichiro
she manages to manifest her demon slayer
mark now faster and stronger mitsuri is
able to buy the others enough time to
track down huntangu's real body a
struggle then ensues as huntangu
increases the size of his original body
and manages to fight back but due to all
the energy that his other demons have
used up he is getting weaker and weaker
now desperate huntangu tries to find
humans to devour in order to replenish
his strength but after muichiro tosses
him a new katana tanjiro manages to take
hantengu's head using hinokamikagura
dancing flash a form that combines
hinokamikagura with zenitsu's
thunderclap and flash technique and yet
even then huntengu doesn't die his
headless body continues to move in an
attempt to reach the humans tangero then
realizes that even that was not the real
body this was another demon clone called
resentment the real body is a tiny demon
who is hiding inside the heart of the
resentment demon the sun is now rising
and tanjiro has to make a terribly
difficult choice
should he save nezuko from the sun or
save the humans from the demon
ultimately he decides to go after the
demon and he ends up cutting down both
the resentment demon body and the
original tiny demon with his flaming
sword as the sun continues to rise and
so within the span of just a few
chapters two upper demon moons are
defeated oh and nezuko survives so you
don't have to worry about her
now let's talk about kaigaku a demon
slayer who betrayed his comrades in
order to become a demon he replaced daki
and yutaro as upper moon 6 and he has a
very personal connection to zenitsu in
chapter 143
zenitsu comes face to face with kaigaku
inside the infinity castle zenitsu was a
disciple of the former thunder hashira
jigoro kwaijima but he wasn't jigoro's
only disciple jigoro's second disciple
was zenitsu senpai and this senpai turns
out to be none other than kaigaku
kaigaku was an orphan who had a very
tough childhood and he was forced to
become a thief and steal scraps of food
just to survive eventually he was taken
in by jigoro and trained to use thunder
breeding just like zenitsu kaigaku was
able to master all of the thunder
breathing forms except for the very
first form which was the only form that
zenith himself was able to master
overall kaiga could seem to be stronger
and more talented than zenitsu and he
believed himself to be a much better
candidate for becoming jigoro's
successor kaigaku hated zenitsu for
being weak cowardly and too familiar
with their master he also frequently
mocked and bullied zenitsu during their
training and for his part zenitsu hated
kaigaku too but he also respected the
impressive strength and swordsmanship
ability that kaigaku demonstrated when
jigoro declared that he wanted both of
his disciples to become his successors
together kagaku was infuriated because
he believed that he was far superior to
zenitsu he didn't think that zenitsu was
worthy of being placed anywhere near the
same level as him because of this
kaigaku abandoned his master he
abandoned the demon slayers and he chose
to become a demon the fact that one of
his own disciples ended up becoming a
demon was so humiliating to jigoro that
he took his own life in order to atone
for his disciples crimes when he learned
about this zenitsu was absolutely
heartbroken and he vowed to one day
defeat kaigaku so once zenitsu and
kagaku actually come face to face inside
the infinity castle it is a deeply
personal and emotional battle the first
major development of this battle is the
reveal that kaigaku despite becoming a
demon is still able to use thunder
breathing but instead of normal
lightning the lightning that accompanies
his attacks in the manga is black
lightning which definitely suits the
design of his demon form as soon as the
battle begins zenitsu manages to
actually cut kaigaku and kaiku is
shocked to learn that zenetsu is far
faster and stronger than he had ever
been before in fact zenitsu seems to be
moving like an entirely different person
now and this underscores just how much
zenith has progressed on his demon
slayer journey kaigaku first became a
demon after he encountered upper moon 1
kokushibo instead of fighting kokushibo
kaigaku knew that he didn't stand a
chance so he just kneeled before the
upper moon's overwhelming strength and
begged kokushibo on his knees to turn
him into a demon kokushiba explains that
turning someone who can use a breathing
technique into a demon requires a great
deal of muzon's blood and there is a
very real risk that his body will simply
reject the blood and he will die but
kaigaku was happy to take the blood and
eventually he did succeed in becoming a
demon after his encounter with kokushibo
whose power is so overwhelming that he
could feel fear in every cell of his
body kaigaku believes that dealing with
zenith will be a piece of cake having
already devoured a large number of
people kaigaku is confident that he is
strong enough to defeat zenitsu and he
attacks with the second form of thunder
breathing called rice spirit he then
quickly transitions into the third form
and the fifth form as black lightning
engulfs the entire room kaigaku is able
to infuse his thunder breathing with his
blood demon art and this allows him to
launch attacks that both slash the
opponent and burn their flesh at the
same time kygaku proclaims that now that
he's become a demon he has actually
surpassed thunder breathing and at first
it looks like he might be right he
manages to cut zenitsu multiple times
and he then throws an injured zenith
from the infinity castle although it
appears that zenitsu is about to fall to
his death zenetsu suddenly uses what
looks like a new form of
thunderbreathing called honoikazuchi no
kami at first kaigaku thinks that jigoro
secretly taught this technique to send
it to only because he liked zenith more
but zenitsu reveals that no he invented
this new seventh form of thunder
breathing because he wanted to be able
to fight alongside kaigaku as his equal
and with this new form zenitsu succeeds
in beheading kaigaku and to be honest it
was a pretty short fight all things
considered kaigaku is furious beyond
words as his head begins to disintegrate
he can't believe that he was defeated by
someone whom he had looked down upon all
this time how could he lose to someone
who was always weaker than him the only
silver lining for kaigaku is the fact
that zenitsu seems to have given up his
own life in order to defeat him zenitsu
no longer has any strength left and it
appears that he will also fall to his
death from the infinity castle kaigaku
tries to convince himself that this
means that he didn't lose the fight
because zenitsu is also going to die
however that is when yushiro shows up
and saves zenitz's life a dying kaigaku
can only watch in despair as yushiro
expresses pity for him and then takes
zenith's motionless body to safety and
even though the fight between zenitsu
and kagaku was short it was extremely
meaningful at the end of the day zenitsu
and kaigaku had pretty similar lives
they were both basically orphans who had
no one to turn to and jigoro became the
closest thing that they had to family
but while kaigaku let his harsh past
define him and while he dedicated his
entire life to his own self-preservation
no matter the cost zenith to recognize
that despite his past hardships there
are people out there like jigoro who
truly loved and accepted him so even
though zenitz was scared for most of his
life and he just wanted to be safe and
lead a normal life he knew that at the
end of the day there were more important
things in this world than just
self-preservation he knew that there
were other people out there who were
worth risking your life for but kaigaku
was just arrogant selfish and obsessed
with his own power and preservation and
so he could never look past his own
selfish needs even after he found
someone who genuinely cared for him like
jigoro he could never be happy because
he always wanted more power and more
recognition this is what led him to
betray everyone he knew this is what led
him to become a demon and this is what
ultimately led to his downfall as he
continued to underestimate zenitsu
because he just couldn't believe that
someone whom he'd consider inferior
could possibly defeat him next up let's
talk about the death of one of the best
villains and demons there upper moon 3
akasa whose final battle takes place
inside the infinity castle against a tag
team effort from tanjiro and gilu in
chapter 146 of the manga akasa confronts
tanjiran giu as they are making their
way through the infinity castle and an
absolutely epic showdown ensues akaza
thinks that his punching attacks will be
enough to take down a weakling like
tanjido but tanjiro immediately
impresses both giu and akaza with his
mastery of hinokami kagura giu even
acknowledges that tanjir's current
ability is equal to a hashida's which is
a huge deal and it really speaks to how
far tangier has come a smiling akisa
then acknowledges that kyoji rorenkoku
was right when he said that tanjiro is
not weak akaza tells tanjiro that he has
earned his respect and then the battle
continues with giu entering the fray at
this point akaza is just excited to be
fighting two respectable opponents and
even remarks that it's been 50 years
since he's gotten to fight against
another water hashida akasa notes that
giu possesses techniques that the other
water hashia that he fought did not and
this emphasizes the point that the
current generation of hashira is clearly
stronger than previous generations
tanjir and giu engage in some really
good teamwork against akaza and giu even
manages to cut off akasa's arm but being
such a strong demon akasa can regenerate
entire limbs in an instant so even an
attack of that magnitude has practically
no effect on him and just in general
this is a really great fight because we
get to see two swordsmen using two
different breathing styles against a
fighter who fights using explosive
punches and kicks it's one of the most
dynamic battles in the series and i can
only imagine how incredible it will look
once it is finally animated but this
fight isn't all about fighting this is
manga after all so of course there is
some talk nojutsu at one point a smiling
akaza says that he is glad that kyojiro
died when he did because he may not have
been able to grow stronger since his
worthless values made him want to stay
human these words infuriate tanjiro who
feels that akaza is mocking kyojiro but
akasa says that no he respects tanjido
and kyojiro because they became strong
he only despises those who are weak and
the law of nature always weeds the weak
out
however tanjiro has a different take on
the law of nature he believes that the
true law of nature dictates that the
strong must protect the weak after all
everyone was weak and helpless as a baby
at some point in their lives and yet
they survived because someone was
willing to protect them everyone starts
out weak but someone is there for them
and protects them until they become
stronger and when they do become
stronger then they should help others
who are weaker than they are this is
actually a really interesting debate
about the law of nature and what it
really means to be strong it reflects
two very different worldviews and it
adds a philosophical element to this
already excellent battle and by the way
this philosophy stuff isn't just talk it
also has a serious effect on the fight
itself because tanjiro's words about
helping others start triggering akusa's
memories of his human life memories that
he had forgotten and suppressed at first
this just makes akaza annoyed with
tanjiro and he begins attacking him even
more ferociously than before i mean this
fight honestly has everything akasa
stopping tanjiro's blade with his bare
hands tanjiro doing his trademark
headbutt on akaza giu coming in clutch
at a crucial time and so much more giu
then awakens his demon slayer mark which
gives him a massive power-up in the
battle against akaza but even with giu's
increased speed and strength akasa is
able to adapt and the fight keeps
dragging on even though giu and tanjiro
don't have any time or energy to spare
if they intend to move on to defeat muza
in his desperation to find a way to
defeat akaza tanjiro thinks back to an
important lesson that his father taught
him and once he does this he finally
unlocks the ability to see into the
transparent world this allows tanjiro to
have better control of his own movements
and also to predict the moves of his
opponent in order to avoid his attacks
at this point tanjiro undergoes a change
his hair and eyes look different and
akaza's instinct tells him that he needs
to kill tanjiro right now because he's
becoming too dangerous thanks to his
newfound ability to access the
transparent world time appears like it's
passing slowly for tanjiro and so he is
able to react much more quickly than
ever before this allows tanjiro to avoid
an attack that akasa thought would for
sure kill him and so while akuza thinks
that tanjiro is already dead tangier is
able to eliminate all ill intentions
from his mind and sneak up on akaza with
a clear mind and access to the
transparent world tanjiro is able to
sneak up on akaza and take his head off
using hinokami kagura akaza is stunned
because in his hundreds of years of
fighting and practicing martial arts he
has never met an opponent who had no
anger or hatred or ill intention or
fighting spirit during a fight tanjiro
seems to have achieved what akasa calls
the domain of supremacy which is nothing
less than a selfless state it means a
sort of flow state without any thought
emotion or preconceived notion it's
basically ultra instinct but in
demonstrator and it's also likely
heavily inspired by the concept of
sunyata in buddhism but that's a topic
for another video akaza is so determined
to keep fighting and get even stronger
that he tries to put his own head back
on giu prevents him from doing that by
moving the head away from the body but
even after the head disintegrates akasa
still doesn't die
somehow someway akasa's headless body is
still alive and fighting and he manages
to kick a shocked tangero into the wall
akaza seems to be following in muzon's
footsteps and trying to reach the point
where he can overcome even losing his
head muzon of course can survive having
his head cut off by a nietzsche in blade
and akkaza is attempting to evolve his
demon form to do exactly that it looks
like akasa's headless body is about to
finish off both giu and tanjiro but then
suddenly akaza begins to remember his
life as a human he sees a woman who
calls him hakuji and with tears flowing
down her face she pulls him by the hand
and says that's enough at first akaza
doesn't recognize this woman but then we
get his backstory born centuries ago in
a very feudal society hakuji was very
poor and as a small boy he had to steal
just to buy medicine for his sick father
he was arrested multiple times and he
was already a repeat offender by the age
of 11. eventually his father took his
own life just so hakuji wouldn't have to
keep stealing for his sake and so he
could go on to live an honorable life
hakuji was extremely upset that his
father who did nothing wrong had to die
just because he was poor so hakuji
constantly rebelled against the feudal
and extremely hierarchical society of
the time he learned how to fight very
well and on one occasion he even beat up
seven adults on his own without even
using a weapon he was then discovered by
a martial arts trainer who saw potential
in him and so hakuji joined this man's
dojo the dojo master put hakuji in
charge of taking care of his sick
daughter koyuki after three years at the
dojo hakuji became extremely close to
his master and koyuki eventually his
master asked hakuji to become his
successor and take over the dojo and
koyuki even confessed her feelings for
him and the two of them were to be
married in that moment hakuji believed
that he could actually start over and
live an honorable life like his father
had always wanted and he would have
given his life to protect his master and
koyuki but then one day while hakuji was
visiting his father's grave people from
a rival dojo who wanted to take over
hakuji's dojo poisoned the well and both
koyuki and her father hakuji's master
died once again someone hakuji loved
died while he wasn't there and he was
powerless to protect them in that moment
hakuji snapped he attacked the rival
dojo and killed 67 of its members with
his bare hands the carnage was so brutal
that the incident was reported as a
demon attack muzon who knew that there
weren't any demons in the area was so
surprised by these reports that he came
to see what was going on for himself
once he found hakuji he injected his
blood into him by force muzon had
already been planning the creation of
the 12 demon moons at the time and he
thought that hakuji aka akaza would make
a great candidate after that akaza lost
his memories and he spent his life
trying to get stronger even though he
had forgotten why he was trying to get
stronger in the first place the real
reason why he wanted to get stronger was
so that he could protect the people he
loved but as a demon who lost his
memories he didn't even realize that all
the people he wanted to protect were
already dead and although the demon
akasa succeeds in regenerating his head
in the present and although giu and
tanjiro were basically defeated at that
point akasa decides to listen to koyuki
as a demon he spent hundreds of years
hating humans because of how weak they
are and he killed many of them but in
reality the one he had wanted to kill
all along was himself because he had
been too weak to protect the people he
loved so instead of continuing the fight
even though he was almost certainly
going to win akaza turns his attack on
himself and then refuses to regenerate
instead of continuing to live as a demon
akasa decides to go home to his father
his master and koyuki akaza aka hakuji
is such a fascinating character because
despite being a demon you can make the
argument that he was never really evil
he was born into very difficult
circumstances and he committed crimes
but he only did it in order to save his
sick father's life by getting him the
medicine he needed then after his
father's tragic death he rebelled
against the type of society that allows
innocent people to perish just because
they happen to be poor but even after
falling into a life of crime he tried to
turn his life around he dedicated
himself to martial arts and he formed a
new family with his master in koyuki and
then the people he loved were taken away
from him by scheming murderers so hakuji
snapped and exacted his revenge on those
who murdered his loved ones and that is
how he got muzon's attention but unlike
other demons who specifically agreed to
accept muzon's blood hakuji tried to
fight muzon however muzan turned out to
be too strong and he then forced his
blood into hakuji to see if he would be
able to handle it after that hakuji lost
his memories and became akaza and being
a demon and fighting was all he knew so
you really could argue that unlike the
other demons who willingly embraced
muzon akaza was as much a victim as he
was a villain and in the end dakaza or
rather hakuji did redeem himself if he
chose to keep going he could have
definitely killed both tanjiro and giu
but instead he chose to stop fighting
and he willingly joined his loved ones
in the afterlife this decision made
muzan's defeat possible because both
tanjiro and giu would go on to play an
important role in muzan's defeat now
it's time to talk about upper moon to
doma who is definitely not a victim and
who has no redeeming qualities in fact
he is probably the most messed up demon
in all of demon slayer and i did an
entire video about him recently where i
argued exactly that point doma's death
occurs as a result of a joint effort by
the insect hashira shinobukocho inosuke
and kano shinobu makes the ultimate
sacrifice during this battle but as a
result of that sacrifice she manages to
avenge her sister and achieve her
ultimate goal
doma is of course the demon who killed
chinobu sister kanae four years earlier
dolma fled the scene before he could
finish kanae off and consume her because
the sun was already coming up and once
shinobu encounters doma inside the
infinity castle he brazenly tells her
how much he regrets that he didn't have
the opportunity to devour her sister as
a furious shinobu attacks doma the
monumental battle against upper moon 2
begins at first dolma isn't worried at
all he thinks that shinobu is just too
weak to defeat him because she's
physically incapable of severing his
head since a demon can't be killed by
just jabbing and stabbing them dolma
will just keep regenerating whenever
shinobu does any damage to him but
shinobu does have one potential
advantage she laced her sword with
powerful wisteria poison which has long
been used to immobilize and defeat
demons but despite stabbing doma
multiple times using the poison laced
weapon the upper moon seems unbothered
because his power as the second most
powerful demon moon allows him to
rapidly develop a resistance to poisons
essentially dolma has multiple major
advantages over shinobu in this battle
and this includes raw physical strength
the ability to regenerate strong
resistance to poison and so on that said
shinobu does have remarkable speed and
this enables her to get around doma's
defenses and pierce and stab him
repeatedly and yet even though she is
able to hurt doma with her attacks
shinobu just can't do any lasting damage
she is too short and physically weak to
take off his head and unless she can
find a way to do that she just can't win
ultimately doma manages to seriously
injure shinobu to the point that she can
barely breathe she's lost a lot of blood
one of her lungs is punctured and it
looks really bad for her but shinobu
still forces herself to stand up even
though every single breath she takes is
painful dolma is shocked that chinobu is
still standing and he even offers to
kill her quickly to end her suffering
but shinobu refuses to give up even in
such an impossibly difficult situation
she attacks doma again using her
incredible speed she is so fast that
even doma the third strongest demon in
the world cannot anticipate her next
move she goes in down low and manages to
pierce doma right through the neck with
her poison laced sword even though she
isn't strong enough to take doma's head
with a single thrust shinobu hopes that
poisoning him in such a vital spot will
be enough to kill him sadly doma still
appears unaffected by the poison poison
just doesn't seem to have a real effect
on him and it's as if all of shinobu's
superhuman efforts have been in vain
doma then grabs shinobu as if he's
hugging her
with tears flowing down his face he
tells shinabu how admirable it is for
her to keep fighting so bravely despite
the fact that her situation is hopeless
she is so weak and she's trying so hard
and doma thinks that this is adorable
doma then adds that because shinobu's
determination has impressed him so much
he now considers her worthy of being
eaten by him so the two of them can be
together forever when doma asks if she
has any last words shinobu tells him to
go to hell then as a helpless kano
watches in disbelief doma begins
absorbing shinabu into his own demon
body kano tries to attack doma and save
shinobu using her flower breathing but
doma is too fast he even smiles and
begins to gloat about how fine feasts
seem to be coming to him one after the
other he is clearly planning to devour
kano as well since doma's victims of
choice are women with strong bodies
despite putting up a good fight and
despite her incredible speed and special
eye powers kano just can't defeat a
demon as strong as doma just as doma
manages to take her sword and it looks
like he's about to kill her inosuke
shows up and saves her an intense battle
then ensues between kano and ninoski on
the one side and dome on the other but
then in a surprising turn of events
shinobu actually returns to the story
despite already being killed and
devoured by doma it turns out that
shinobu knew ahead of time that in order
to defeat her sister's killer the
notorious upper moon to doma she would
have to give up her own life that was
her plan from the start she knew that
doma was a glutton who loved devouring
women in particular and she also knew
that he wouldn't be able to resist
devouring a female hashida with a strong
body so shinobu started ingesting
wisteria flower poison little by little
for over a year so that she would build
a resistance to it the goal was for her
to have a ton of that poison circulating
throughout her body when doma decided to
devour her with her sword alone shinobu
was able to deliver only a small amount
of poison into doma's body but if he
consumes her entire body he will
automatically consume 70 times the
lethal amount of wisteria poison the
author of demon slayer later stated in
the extra pages to volume 19 that she
actually intended for the number to be
700 times the lethal amount but she
mistakenly wrote 70. that said the
official translation for this part of
the manga at viz.com still says 70 and
not 700. as doma is facing off against
kano and inosuke all that poison that he
ingested without even realizing it
finally begins to take effect his body
breaks down completely his very bones
begin to melt and even with his demonic
regeneration he cannot undo the effects
of such an immense amount of poison
dolma desperately tries to keep fighting
but kanoa and osuke work together to cut
off his head and with that upper moon to
doma is finally destroyed as he is dying
doma meets shinobu once again somewhere
between this life and the next shinobu
sees firsthand that she succeeded in her
mission and now doma must accept his
death at her hands and yet dolma is not
sad angry or scared about what happened
in fact he tells shinobu that he finally
understands what love is because he
knows that he loves her the very act of
killing him impressed doma so much that
he has now fallen in love with shinobu
even though he has never felt like this
about anyone ever before doma asks
shinobu if she would accompany him to
hell in the tone of a man who was asking
his crush out on a date and cheetah
smiles and says after you you worthless
bastard doma really was a special kind
of crazy and even though i have a lot to
say about him there's no need to get
into that here because i have an entire
video that analyzes doma as a character
i will link that video down in the
description if you guys want to check it
out but now it's time to talk about the
death of the strongest demon moon upper
moon one kokushibo his final battle
takes place inside the infinity castle
and he fights against muichiro sanemi
gyome and genya at the same time that is
three hashira and another demonstrator
with special demonic powers against a
single demon muchiro is the first to
encounter kokushibo and he senses right
away that kokushibo must have been a
demon slayer back when he was human
kokushibo has an overwhelming and
majestic presence and it is clear that
he is a master swordsman in fact the
strongest demon moon has such an
intimidating aura that muichiro begins
to shake and his body doesn't even want
to fight which is something that has
never happened to him before
this speaks to just how overpowered
kokushibo really is even his mere
presence makes even the bravest and most
powerful warriors shake in terror as
muichiro tries to get a hold of himself
kokushibo calmly asks for his name
muichiro identifies himself and
kokushiba responds that his own human
name was michikatsu tsugikuni although
the tsugikuni name must have died out
over time kokushibo can tell that
muichiro is a descendant of his own
child this means that kokushibo is a
direct ancestor of muichiro this comes
as news to muichiro but regardless he
musters the courage to steal his nerves
and prepare for combat kukushibo
commends muichiro's spiritual strength
and ability to calm his nerves so
quickly muichiro then initiates the
first attack on kokushi by using missed
breathing even though the hashida isn't
able to land a single blow the upper
moon is still impressed by muichiro's
strength and courage especially since he
can tell that muichiro is only 14.
kokushibo also notices that the demon
sire mark has now appeared on muitro's
face and as muichiro continues to use
impeccable technique in an attempt to
hit kokushibo the upper moon decides
that it would be poor etiquette if he
didn't draw his own sword and
sokokushibo reveals his demonic
breathing style moon breathing
unfortunately for muichiro literally the
first swing of kokushibo's moon
breathing slices off his left hand
muichiro quickly makes a tourniquet from
his shirt and he keeps on fighting
practically unfazed by the sudden loss
of his hand kokushibo is so impressed by
the resilience of his descendant that he
decides that killing him would be a
shame instead kokushibo will ask muzon
to turn muichiro into a demon muichiro
is then literally pinned down to a
pillar with a sword so he can't really
do anything to kokushibo but that is
when genya shows up genya tries to sneak
up on kokushibo and shoot him from
behind but kokushibo is already aware of
genya's presence and using his
incomprehensible speed he manages to cut
genya into pieces
but to kokushibo's surprise genya is
still alive due to his own demonic
powers and before he can finish genya
off kokushibo is also attacked by
genya's brother the wind hashira sanemi
sanemi vows to make kokushibo pay for
slicing up his little brother and after
kokushiba draws his own sword we get to
see an absolute fierce battle between
wind breathing and moon breathing
eventually the stone hashirag gyome also
joins the fight and everything is ready
for the final showdown and while the
fight between moon breathing and stone
breathing rages the unbelievably
impressive muichiro manages to pull the
sword that had been pinning him to that
pillar out of his own chest with his
bare hands now muichiro knows that he
will likely die from blood loss as a
result of the injuries that he has
already sustained but he is determined
to do something useful before he dies he
does his best to wrap his wounds and
stop the bleeding and then he helps
genya put himself back together although
both of these guys are badly hurt they
both declare that they will keep
fighting until the very end genya is
able to consume some of kokushibo's own
cells and then he and muichiro try to
pick themselves up from the ground and
rejoin the fight as that is happening
gyome and tsunemi are already tag
teaming kokushibo in a desperate attempt
to take his head and defeat him muichiro
finally rejoins the battle when he steps
in to save sanemi from one of
kokushibo's attacks and then determined
to help while he is still able to move
muichiro attacks kokushibo while
kokushibo is distracted by attacks from
gyome and sanemi muichiro manages to
move close enough to pierce kokushiba's
torso with his sword muichiro even loses
one of his legs in the process but he
doesn't care muchiro is prepared for
death and he just wants to be as useful
as he possibly can before he dies
muichiro is not only one of the most
talented hashida in history but also one
of the most brave and selfless and his
performance during this fight is truly
amazing by putting his life on the line
muichiro is able to keep kakushiba
pinned down in place long enough for
genya to shoot him and once he is shot
by genya's bullets the blood demon art
activates this blood demon arch creates
a treat that wraps all around
kokushiba's body and prevents him from
moving unfortunately soon after
kokushibo sprouts blades all over his
body and these blades are able to slice
up the tree and free him muichiro who is
still right next to kokushibo and still
piercing him with his sword decides that
he must protect yomma and sanami at all
costs so that they can survive and
contribute to the fight against muzon he
is so determined to help defeat
kokushibo before he dies that his
nichiren blade suddenly turns red and
this newly evolved blade causes such
pain to kokushibo that he is unable to
move a dying genya then reactivates that
tree blood demon art one more time
helping to keep kokushibo immobile long
enough for sonomi and gyomei to
decapitate him at first it looks like
kokushiba's power is so great that even
decapitation cannot defeat him to
everyone's shock he is able to
regenerate even his head
but this second head looks nothing like
a human head it is a monstrous demonic
head and when kokushibo catches a
glimpse of his own face he is disgusted
kokushibo is of course the twin brother
of yorichi tsugikuni the legendary
breath of the sun user kokushibo wanted
to become the strongest swordsman in the
world but he eventually realized that he
would never surpass his incredibly
talented twin brother yorichi had
godlike talent that simply could not be
surpassed and despite the fact that
kokushibo was an incredibly strong
swordsman back when he was human he was
never good enough to compete with his
brother even though kokushibo felt
compassion for his brother at first
after yorici's superhuman talents
started to manifest jealousy consumed
kokushibo because he knew that no matter
what he did and no matter how hard he
tried he would never be able to surpass
his brother kokushibo even abandoned his
family in order to dedicate his life to
becoming a demon slayer he trained with
yorichi he learned the secret of
breathing styles and he even manifested
the demon slayer mark but still he was
nowhere close to matching yorichi
kokushibo's breathing style was only an
inferior derivative of sun breathing
called moon breathing and since every
demonstrator who manifested the mark
died by the age of 25 except for yurichi
of course kokushiba found himself
staring death in the face without having
accomplished his goal of becoming the
strongest samurai and surpassing his
brother and that is when muzon
approached him muzon had been looking
for a skilled swordsman who could use
breathing techniques so that he could
turn him into a demon and that is what
he offered to kokushibo if kokushivo
became a demon he would not die at the
age of 25 he would not have to deal with
the limitations of a human body and he
would have all of eternity to train
until he really became the strongest
samurai of all time kokushibo took the
deal he became a demon and he started
cutting down all demon players in order
to clear a path for him and muzon to
live forever but even 60 years after
becoming a demon kokushibo still wasn't
able to surpass yorichi the two brothers
came face to face again when yorichi was
already in his 80s kokushibo was a demon
who didn't age so he was still at peak
strength but yorichi was a frail old man
and yet yorichi was still stronger than
kokushibo his technique was so flawless
that he still defeated his brother in
battle however yurichi died of old age
before he had a chance to strike the
finishing blow so kokushiba survived the
battle but he was forced to live another
400 years with the knowledge that even
as an old man yorichi was still stronger
than him kokushibo abandoned his family
his comrades and his very humanity to
surpass his brother and to avoid defeat
but in the end he still didn't achieve
his dream not only did he fail to kill
yurichi but he also failed to become the
strongest samurai that is because
yorichi became a monster not a samurai a
samurai doesn't become a demon instead
of accepting defeat with honor a samurai
doesn't devour people just to get
stronger and the samurai doesn't have
the face of a grotesque monster faced
with this cruel truth kokushibo can't
believe that he allowed his fear of
defeat to turn him into such an inhuman
creature due to kokushibo's severe
crisis of conscience his body begins to
break apart in the place that muichiro
had stabbed him with his red blade
kokushibo is then finished off by gyoume
and tsunami and so finally after nearly
500 years of life upper moon one
kokushibo falls down in defeat kenya and
muichiro both die from the wounds that
they suffered in the battle against
kokushibo but saneme and gyome live long
enough to contribute to the final battle
against muzan
the final upper moon that we need to
talk about is nakime who briefly serves
as a replacement for upper moon 4
hunting goo after hunting gus defeat she
is a biwa playing demon who controls the
infinity castle using the strings of her
biwa and she also has the ability to spy
on others by releasing multiple eyeballs
from her body that can move on their own
and keep track of her enemies i won't
spend too much time on nakimen because
she is not a fighter and her death is
quite sudden and anticlimactic once all
the upper moons except for nakime are
defeated the focus of the demon slayers
turns to fighting muzon after yushiro
takes control of nakima's vision and
begins using the infinity castle against
muzon muzon simply kills nakime by
crushing her head which prevents yushiro
from continuing to use nakima's powers
against him and that is it every upper
moon's death in demon slayer explained
be sure to let me know down in the
comments who your favorite upper moon is
and which of them do you think went out
in the most epic fashion and please
don't say knocking because i'll know
you're lying if you're looking for a
video to watch next check out my video
that breaks down every hashida's
backstory link in the description if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more videos like this in the future just
leave a quick like it only takes a
second but it really helps a lot and if
you want to support the channel directly
for free don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications i mean if you made it
all this way in this long long video
then i'm sure you would enjoy my other
content so don't forget to subscribe you
can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at animeopror as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see ya space cowboys